hi
bros
i know art
i know luxury i know taste
i am taste
today i will choose which one cheap
which one expensive
you will play along let's go which
jacket costs close to 2 000.
okay well i know i know i know it's b
i know it's b there's no doubt because
they said it's montclair and there's no
way that's and they spelled it wrong
didn't it it's not montclair oh never
mind yeah that ain't montclair that's
the montclair b please told you [ __ ] i
know expansion
[Music]
come on easy i actually expected this to
be a little difficult but i guess not
all right which of these car shirt costs
around 350. well it's definitely a
yeah the b's is a meme shirt i feel like
b
could be but i definitely would have
seen it if it was expensive that's how
deep i am in dumb luxury products come
on do i know the difference between a
[ __ ] rolex and daniel wellington yes
i do thank you what the [ __ ] is this
even just by looking at them even if you
didn't see the brian you would know a is
more expensive come on although we'd
watch this i will say that's one of
those things where like you remove the
brand a lot of times you can't tell
right so it kind of contradicts what i
just said but you know what i mean
anyhow uh which pair of jeans cost
around 450 this is a little tougher i
would
[Music]
one is amazon the other one's diesel i'm
pretty sure it's a having really heavy
jeans
uh they look like a really long cut too
washed that way i think it's pretty
expensive it's rare to see really
expensive god i became such a snob i did
this as a joke
i'd say i went wrong they're 25 bucks
[ __ ] me i take back everything i was so
confident okay good i needed that i
needed a little backer running okay one
is amazon the other one is bedwin i'm
gonna have to guess b but
just from the sheer
size and uniform pattern i feel like
when you add a bunch of stuff like this
it kind of cheapens it a little bit
all right so we got yeezys or what is it
converse adidas
or converse what which one am i supposed
to guess the yeezys oh this is a tough
one i think b i think b yeah it looks
like that
uh weird fabric that a lot of expensive
oh it's bulgaria okay is it just me have
you gone equally good so far i don't
know i don't wear jackets i actually
have no idea realistically would amazon
sell
the b type pattern yeah they would
maybe a yeah okay pure logic i mean it's
50 50 at the end of the day
uh which pen and class class to 500 i
don't know honestly this one i have no
idea i'll have to go with b all right
cool seven out of nine
i know expensive
okay moving on i want to test this on
art if i can tell
expensive art from cheap art right which
is the most expensive one is that what
i'm guessing which of these artwork is
worth more i would guess the pies the
pies look lit hell yeah who wouldn't
want that
this i wouldn't want i don't want to
hang that
what the hell is thanks i can't even see
what it is i'm i'm going with pipes
thank you how do i pick it i can't pick
it are you going to show me the answers
all right guess this is how we're doing
it which of these color fields is more
expensive we got ornament
six that's not a pretentious title at
all or cherry field by la liza lisa
charney i'm gonna go with barney
43
whoa
bro
oh my god dude
jesus christ
that is insane
oh it's huge okay
but still what are you
um oh
it looks better small
co-founder 43 minutes
no
no get out of here
stop dude that looks like you put
masking tape in the middle i bet that's
what they did oh no
oh no oh god i mean
art is subjective felix and
a lot of times what you like other
people don't like and but oh
ah these oh this sucks this [ __ ]
sucks this sucks so bad
this is so bad dude what the [ __ ]
it's not even a good blue it's not even
a good blue i hate it i hate it i hate
you all right a potato that's funny or
slowed down by a rose piper uh
i don't know
i
this
oh a million a million dollars you know
people rip into nfts right what the [ __ ]
is this then the [ __ ] is this it's a
nice potato i guess it's very detailed
how much did this painting entitled
salvador mundi
by leonardi da vinci well i know you
know everyone knows leonardo da vinci i
feel like this is a trick question and
maybe originally it was sold for this
prize or something now it was 450
million okay all right you that should
have been obvious really
bro half a billion half a billion i mean
leonardo da vinci i've never seen that
artwork like i've seen a ton of leonardo
da vinci you ain't seen it's kind of
cool though he's holding like a bang and
he's doing like a korean love sign right
that's kind of sick looks like jesus too
can you guess how much yeah this is
awful this is there's bad art i don't
like it that probably means it's really
expensive yeah there you go [ __ ]
they wanted a dirty freight
that wasn't a tartan i mean what am i
looking at i can't even tell what's legs
whose leg is this looks like one of
those bad optical illusion photos we're
like is that him is that the point maybe
maybe i don't get the art
stop it and why are they all looking in
different ways it makes no sense bro
just look in the camera dummies bruh
bro i you know how they always say
oh i could draw better than that and i
always go no you [ __ ] can't in my
head but i can draw better than that and
i sh i'm doing it now
like the legs make no sense
they look like they look like they're in
their sleep bags
he looks like a little worm or she not
judging anyway what price did the card
player sell for it's kind of cool the
perspective makes no sense this guy is
showing up his entire hand it doesn't
even look like cards they haven't put
down a single card on the table it looks
like two men just trading pokemon cards
or some [ __ ] or stamps or letters i hope
it's four million because that's the
love
[Music]
i don't want to be the pretentious guy
that says well imagine if you gave it
all away and maybe
but bruh 250 million you could save a
country
you could be right
it
this sucks this sucks can you correctly
identify how much interchange sold for
okay so here we have some abstract art
which i think gets more than it deserves
and it i think this is a good example of
what i was saying earlier where people
like i can draw that no you can okay it
takes balance it takes colors it takes
coordination it takes a perfect eye to
find something beauty in the random
shape and patterns okay thanks but it's
still it's still 10 million ah 300 300
this one is the first one i like
actually this is beautiful
this one i hope 500 oh it's the cheapest
one
stop
what the what is up with r it's the rule
the uglier the more it sells for this i
know the artist is that guy with the r
r
it's a
rock
rock what's his name is it roh
well this is 86 million yeah and because
i know it's
rotco yes rotco everyone love a ratco oh
my god is that that rotco
i love it it's like colors the thing is
like i like it i'm not here to hate the
art i think yeah it's pretty painting
[Music]
about 86 million adam
it's also kind of sad i don't know if
this is true of rothko but i assume it
is where you know the value always
shoots up after the artist passes
because then there's a finite supply of
these uh
artworks and and that's
obviously basic economics that makes the
price surge up so a lot of times the
artist isn't paid anything right it's
just exchange of money between rich
people at the end of the day that uh i
mean fine i mean you this is i
uh i kind of get it now like i no i
don't get it i mean i was just um i
don't yeah how much did
so many thoughts how much the number
okay
yeah this is one of those crazy ones i
bet you 100 at least
[Music]
this looks [ __ ] terrible this is like
the worst no go back you're not getting
away you're not getting away from me
who's the artist maybe it looks better
up close jackson pollock bro this is bad
you know what they do with artists too
after they die they take literally every
single thing they [ __ ] ever touch
their hand on and they try and sell it
right when in reality imagine if that
happened to you right you make a little
doodle drop penis and like i don't
really like that but whatever
people sell it and like
this is not a representation this feels
like one of that i'm not saying this guy
is a bad artist all i'm saying is maybe
this was not his finest piece of work
like this i can kind of [ __ ] you know
this is kind of dope this yeah even this
i like it's got red in it i like red
yeah this i like them this is dope it's
all right i can see it i can definitely
see the eye this is awful right surely
he failed sometimes 200 millions just
because it's his name all right i bet
you even pollock will be like yeah you
know what number 17a i was kind of just
experimenting it kind of turned look
like [ __ ]
but it is fools how much was any warhol
sold for sheesh
that's cr
what the most iconic piece of art i've
ever seen is less than all of these i
don't i don't know art i take back
everything i said i have no clue what's
happening this is crazy what for what
price did wheat field site this is i
don't like it i hope below 10 million
all right cool anytime i don't like it
any time i don't like it
how many millions of dollars depending
black fire eye sell for
there's no fire let me tell you that so
it fails immediately 84 now 80 growing
this is beautiful
i like this 85
nailed it i like this
90. how many how many more are they like
do you oh it keeps going
all right let's move away from art
because it's just pissing me off let's
go back to fashion how much is this
balenciaga evening dress five thousand
with fashion especially just like the
more outrageous it is the more it costs
absolutely and i guess it's the same
with art really how much is this
valencia yeah it's the most expensive
one no it isn't okay
[ __ ] i guess i'm wrong there's no
consistency i don't understand any of
these how much is a three pack of cotton
t-shirts from prada we need to call
charlie we need charlie to get it
uh three pack of prada
this is like the rich man's how much is
a gallon of milk can you
gain your name can you name the price of
a three pack of white cotton t-shirt
prawn i think 340 or 440 i got 340.
there you go yeah i'm still down with my
humble roots
that feels good to me
oh god
hey we got the balenciaga triple s's
they go for 9.95 [ __ ] oh god i knew
that didn't i
all right i think that's it
you get it art is stupid i'm smart and i
think you are smart as well because
you're subscribed to this channel and so
i think we learned a lot here today
thank you for watching see you tomorrow
ba ba ba bro fist a mental brofist
because you're way further than
yeah all right yeah mental brofist
we just linked up that's awesome you
thought it was gay but true relevance
never really died
welcome to the first undead game use any
item in your inventory and make memes
inside tuber simulator add some of our
patented stickers in there stickers our
emotions memes our emotions express your
emotions with me
show them for likes share them for love
get up for free
and who knows
maybe i'll review your memes the
greatest honor of all time full circle
baby download it make a meme
we need subtitles on this